un esfuerzo por corregir errores
históricos alemania anunció que había
llegado a un acuerdo con namibia
reconociendo oficialmente sus asesinatos
coloniales entre 1904 en 1908 como
genocidio de miles de personas de las
etnias herero y nama por parte del
ejército alemán özil estos animales
vick nuestra meta es encontrar un camino
conjunto para una reconciliación en
memoria de las víctimas para ello
debemos reconocer claramente los
asesinatos de la época colonial alemana
en la actual namibia especialmente los
cuales hechos entre los años 1904 y 1908
cannes cloud hoy declaramos aquellos
hechos oficialmente como lo que fue un
genocidio
estas más con ello reconocemos también
nuestra responsabilidad histórica
stamets auctions ballester sin fan foto
alemania también dijo que financiaría un
programa de reconstrucción y desarrollo
valorado en 1.100 millones de euros para
beneficiar a las comunidades afectadas
por las
se espera que la ayuda cubre a proyectos
de infraestructura atención sanitaria y
formación profesional durante 30 años el
imperio alemán fue la potencia colonial
en lo que entonces se llamaba el áfrica
sudoccidental alemana entre 1884 de 1915
los historiadores dicen que las tropas
alemanas mataron a 65.000 herederos y
10.000 na más entre 1904 y 1908 los
supervivientes fueron expulsados al
desierto donde muchos murieron de sed o
acabaron en campos de concentración para
ser utilizados como mano de obra esclava
por el tour los alemanes hicieron pasar
penurias a mi abuela corrió sola creció
entre gente extranjera y la obligaron a
hablar una lengua extranjera
vivimos en la pobreza por lo que nos
hicieron en su momento ahora queremos
que nos devuelvan nuestra dignidad que
nos reparen y queremos que nos devuelvan
nuestra tierra aunque alemania ha
reconocido anteriormente su
responsabilidad moral por las matanzas
había evitado presentar una disculpa
oficial 2015 berlín inició negociaciones
formales con el gobierno de namibia para
un acuerdo que incluyera una